Okay.
I want to talk about Peter the great today.
And,
um,
I,
you know,
the Russian empire is one of those empires that,
that,
that continued,
uh,
arguably not arguably that's the case.
Uh,
after,
uh,
the MPAA four empires disappeared with World War One.
Well,
the Russian empire continues.
So it continues under a somewhat a different,
a very different,
uh,
um,
in a different way,
uh,
with the,
what became the Soviet Empire because that's what it would,
it became a,
and of course,
with the,
with the end of a,
of the Soviet Union in 1991,
92,
um,
the Soviet empire collapsed.
So Union claps,
and I guess the only remaining empire in the world is that of the United States,
I,
which is a more informal empire,
but still one that is out there almost everywhere with it,
uh,
military basis,
everywhere.
So the rise and fall of empires is,
is,
is obviously a theme of,
uh,
of this course.
And the Russian empire.
The state of Moscow v,
uh,
had already begun,
had already expanded greatly,
but it's really Peter the great,
it's the Big Guy who expanded,
uh,
Russia,
as territorial size,
uh,
enormously.
Um,
and so,
you know,
Ma Muscovy had been one of the tributaries of the Mongols who sacked Kiev in
the,
in the 12th 30s,
a after pouring into Russia.
And what now is Ukraine,
um,
and,
and Muscovy was,
it was a prince that was a,
uh,
was a,
a princely state.
And it gradually expanded in size or reaching the southern euro mountains in the
Caspian Sea and,
and emerging as a dynastic,
uh,
state.
Uh,
but yet,
uh,
Muscovy was considerably less important than the Commonwealth of Poland
Lithuania,
uh,
which was considerably much,
a greater and subject to,
uh,
struggles with and influenced by,
that,
that state.
Um,
and it's what Peter,
the great,
uh,
did was he pushed back.
The neighbors who had blocked the expansion of,
of Moscow have Muscovy,
uh,
that is Sweden who me defeats in a battle worth noting.
And Poltava Polt Ava,
it's in the book 1709,
Poland and the Ottoman Turks,
uh,
Peter,
the great ads territory beyond the euro mountains along the Caspian Sea,
at the expense of the Turks.
Uh,
like all of his successors,
he dreamed of conquering the Turkish con capa capital of Constantinople that as
Istanbul,
which have given him control of the Straits,
would have given them control of the Straits.
Uh,
um,
uh,
the Dardanelles Straits are there,
the passage between Europe and in Asia leading to the Black Sea and I,
all that stuff really matters because all of these events now with,
with,
uh,
the problems in Georgia,
and that's a very,
very delicate to,
uh,
a strange situation where the great power now in the United States finds itself
rather in Congress.
They arguing that that Kosovo,
which should be a obviously independent,
I remember going to patch him in Kosovo when I was a kid.
Uh,
that that is a little hard to argue that closable should be independent and,
and that what was the territorial,
a unit of Serbia should not be respected.
I agree with this because of oil should be independent and to argue that Tibet
should be,
should be free.
And I agree with that.
And then it turned around and argue that the people in,
in,
in Georgia who are not Georgians,
uh,
should not have the same rights that the people in closer we'll have.
Uh,
the whole thing of the presentation and the in the,
in the press process,
absolutely hypocritical and just,
just,
just bizarre.
But the only point of that little diatribe,
uh,
in parentheses,
was that the Black Sea really does still matter a lot.
And,
and that,
that Peter the Great was the first,
uh,
of the,
of the Russian tsars to dream of,
of this access on a,
the to the Black Sea.
Uh,
and then finally,
uh,
to controlling of this traits of Constantinople and Catherine the great are they
all like to call themselves the great,
uh,
she would,
make this an important part of her policy,
but she doesn't get there either.
Uh,
and in the 19th century,
uh,
the Russians,
ours are still trying to get there.
Uh,
uh,
as well of a Peter's new fleet.
We'll talk about his new fleet,
which he oversaw it.
And even in a very minor way,
help build himself a sales don the Don River in 1698.
And it takes the Turkish port of,
uh,
as off a,
a z o s v on the Sea of as off a z o v a.
And this gave them access to the Black Sea,
but then they're forced to a backup.
They lose and they're,
they're forced to,
uh,
to,
to a surrender as off to the Turks after an unsuccessful war.
And so Peter the Great,
despite his dramatic expansion of,
um,
uh,
of the,
of the Russian empire,
uh,
does not get this outlet on a of the Black Sea.
Uh,
but what,
what,
what does change and,
and the rep,
what the Battle of Representatives,
of course it's Poltava is that Russia's participation in European affairs had
been,
had been totally minimal.
I'm is a story often told and even told in the book that you're kind enough to
read,
uh,
that I think it was Louis the 14th that his,
equivalent of Minister of foreign affairs sends a letter,
a formal letter to a Russian czar who couldn't amend Louie the 14th.
But one of those dudes,
uh,
I mean,
it might've been a two,
a czar who had been dead for 12 years.
Uh,
Russia was,
was that far away and it was not in the,
of,
uh,
of the great,
of the great powers.
Um,
but after,
uh,
one of Peter's victories,
the Russian ambassador in Vienna reported that the news of Peter's victory
began.
People began to a fear of the czars formally,
Eh,
formerly as they feared Sweden.
And it's very difficult to us to imagine a fear of Sweden.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the,
the fear of,
uh,
the,
the last real Gustavus Adolphus during the,
during the,
uh,
the 30 years war with the last release or major,
a Swedish interlude and continental European affairs,
uh,
they'll Poltava it doesn't come to defeat of Poltava,
doesn't come till a toll.
1709.
Um,
so,
uh,
of what,
um,
but what he does is that,
he,
I there's no other European state expanding their empires overseas in the case
of the Spanish and the English that adds so much territory,
uh,
on land to its empire,
um,
between the 1620s,
uh,
and the 1740s,
the,
the land of the empire and the Russian Empire increases from 2.1 million square
miles to 5.9 million square miles.
Now,
to be sure,
uh,
in Siberia,
in the far reaches of,
of the north of,
of North Asia,
uh,
this empire amounted to little more than a series of trading posts.
Uh,
and it took a very long time for any sort of semblance of Russian authority from
Moscow and soon from Saint Petersburg for reasons that we'll see to reach there.
But,
but nonetheless,
uh,
Peter the great creates this huge empire that will have over the alarm went and
enormous influence in European affairs because after all,
uh,
Russia,
European,
Russia is part of Europe,
uh,
and we'll have an enormous influence,
on Asian affairs as well.
A witness,
the Russell Japanese war,
uh,
in 1904,
1905,
uh,
that the Russians lose.
And this is a key moment in the evolution of revolutionary politics in Russia as
we,
uh,
she'll,
and we shall see,
uh,
a little later on.
Now what about Peter?
The great,
I used to ask my friend publish Covich to come in and call you to give the
lecture.
And then I guess we're interested in it that I,
I did some reading on my own.
I,
Leslie,
what's her name?
Um,
uh,
Lindsay Hughes and,
and,
and the various other people.
And so puts this together.
Um,
uh,
last semester,
because he is not a terribly engaging or you know,
warm personality in many ways since he enjoyed watching people being tortured.
I including his own son.
Uh,
but he is an interesting person and one of the things he does,
and I guess this is one of the,
you know,
the things that we put in neon from this lecture is he opens up Russia,
which had no secular influences at all to western ideas.
Uh,
and so this is an extraordinarily important and transforming,
uh,
accomplishment of Peter the great he emerges from the violent world of Boyer.
Boilers are the nobles.
Yonkers are the Prussian Nobles,
boy,
ours,
boy ar are the Russian Knowles and royal politics.
Peter was the first child of his father's second wife,
and thus a potential threat to the ambition of the relatives of the first wife,
uh,
his mother and her allies among the boy that is the nobles over through the
regions in 16,
uh,
89,
Peters rule is from 1682 till his death in 1725.
Uh,
there were no strict rules for the succession of the Tsar.
It's basically just kind of a family [inaudible] family battle royal,
uh,
in which,
there were bloody a settling of scores and there was no foreign minister.
Uh,
the boy are counsel.
That is the council of the nobles literally met in the throne,
uh,
of the palace.
Uh,
and it became known as the Duma.
Eventually in 1905,
uh,
Nicholas,
the second,
uh,
will be forced to,
to grant a Duma a,
an assembly to Russia.
And then he withdraws,
eliminates basically all of its rights.
And then the doom,
of course we'll come back,
uh,
later on now,
Peter is one of those cases in European history where the one person's
personality and interest does make an enormous difference because he is an
absolute ruler.
He can do what he damn well pleases.
And he is personally responsible for the reforms.
Uh,
the opening up of Russia to a considerable extent to,
uh,
to European ideas,
to western European ideas.
This is something that he does himself as a boy.
He was at very smart and he was very interested in science.
He wanted to know always how things work.
He was fascinated with astrolabes and,
uh,
was interested in sailing.
Now Russia doesn't have a port.
Uh,
so he's interested in sailing,
learns about sailing on,
on,
on lakes and ponds and rivers.
Uh,
it does have a port,
but it's frozen in with frozen all the time.
Um,
but his travels took them into contact with observatories,
museums,
hospitals,
botanical gardens.
When he goes,
he's fascinated by gardens.
When he goes to Europe,
uh,
on his,
on his big salty on his big,
big boy trek through Europe.
And he goes around and he visited visits,
all of these,
you know,
botanical gardens and he sketches things.
He's constantly sketching the way things work,
the way things are.
He had an intellectual curiosity that really defied the kind of Orthodox,
religious,
uh,
a skepticism about any kind of rational belief.
I mean,
this permeated,
and not only the Russian Orthodox church,
but appear meets,
uh,
the Catholic church as well.
I mean,
look what happens to Galileo,
uh,
who,
you know,
who was lucky not to have been burned at the stake,
uh,
by,
by his friend of the pope.
And he was interested in math and in geography and thus in maps and map making.
Um,
and when he does is he takes this archaic state structure in which literally
nothing had been written down.
It's all just,
you know,
passed down from word to mouth.
He transforms,
it transforms Russia into a European absolute monarchy with much in common with
Frederick the great with Sweden,
uh,
with Austria,
Austria,
the Habsburgs,
uh,
with Spain and with,
with,
with France.
Um,
he,
he tries a,
not only to copy European absolutism,
but to open up Russia to commerce,
realizing that trade met wealth and that wealth met improvements in the lives of
the Russian people.
More about that in a while.
Uh,
so he makes Russia,
uh,
a military,
power indeed,
arguably a modern military power,
at least in the,
in the 17th and early 18th century.
Um,
uh,
sansony injects European culture in to,
into Russia now.
Just as an aside,
but it's wonderful.
We'll come back to a,
particularly in your reading,
the tension in Russia between an absolute repugnance for Western influence.
Uh,
and,
and the,
the,
the assert under the assertion constant assertion that that Russia traditional
ways of doing things are the right way of doing things.
I long identified with people who would be called Slavo.
Phil's,
uh,
their tensions with Westernized.
Hers would last right through Russian intellectual history in the 19th century.
I remember when I was,
you know,
a student of one of the biggest classes at the University of Michigan go blue.
I'm so sad this weekend.
Uh,
it was Russian intellectual history and we would read the Slava fuels and we'd
read the Western icers.
Uh,
of course taught by the late Russian,
a restaurant of scholar of Russia.
Uh,
Arthur Mendel.
And it was fabulous to read these people as they debated,
you know,
what will happen to Russia,
the kind of Western icers and those in between.
And a lot of them,
they were writing from Paris in the 19th century in some of them were just
great,
great writers and was just kind of intellectual energy.
But it came down to this theme that's still is so important,
uh,
was already so important,
is that what is Russian that should be kept uniquely Russian and closed outside
influence.
And what is Russian that should be modified by being open to non religious
influences that come from other places.
And this is not just a uniquely Russian tail as obviously,
uh,
you can see now what about Peter Himself?
He was,
we figured that somebody figured out at least six foot seven.
Now that's just huge.
That's tiny in the NBA now,
but six points that the guards,
the,
the sort of giants,
they were called who garden,
uh,
Frederick the great,
we're giants because there were six feet tall.
The average person was about 5.3,
uh,
five feet,
three inches,
five,
four in,
in,
uh,
in France.
Napoleon was always considered to be kind of a,
you know,
a dwarf,
a midget,
uh,
really was about the,
he wasn't at all,
he was just sort of regional corpulent,
but he was the average kind of increasingly corporate and he was the average
height of most people in France.
So in a Peter the Great was a big guy,
six foot seven.
Uh,
he had extremely small hands,
very small feet,
which meant he sort of lurched,
uh,
and stumbled sometimes when he walked quickly cause he drank just enormous
quantities.
And he had these odd kind of facial tics that he couldn't,
he couldn't really help at all.
Uh,
we there,
we don't have,
you know,
we don't have a,
uh,
documentary showing Peter the great inaction for obvious,
um,
uh,
obvious reasons.
But the people that he visited,
I,
when he was snatching a huge roasts off the table at,
at the fancy parties in,
uh,
in London,
commented on these sort of facial tics that he had that would bend his face.
And he had a misshapen,
uh,
lower lip.
Um,
and his t his head sometimes when he was talking with would seem convulsed to
the right.
It would kind of move to the right all the time.
And he was so much bigger than everybody else.
And so people really were,
were,
uh,
not taken aback.
I,
because this was a time when,
when,
when physical imperfections,
we're,
uh,
we're commonplace.
I mean,
you couldn't go anywhere without seeing people who,
uh,
who,
who nature had given a,
in many ways a very bad deal along with crushing poverty.
Uh,
but the fact that Peter was a czar and,
and,
and was rather scary in his temperament because he had a rather bad temper,
uh,
to,
method.
He could be,
he could be alarm,
he could be scary.
His cruelty,
generosity was legend,
but so has this cruelty,
uh,
several times at public executions in 1698 and 1699,
he brushed the executioner away,
grabbed the accident,
did the dirty work himself chopping off a ahead or two a night.
In 17,
18,
he ordered a man,
uh,
kept alive after being horribly tortured.
So he could be a tortured,
some more and suffer as long as humanly possible.
Uh,
all officials,
uh,
in,
from the chancelleries that he had created and all of the officers were obliged
to attend this torture scene as a way of kind of warning them that,
uh,
you know,
you better not mess around.
Now remember,
this is a time as we'll see in a while where,
you know,
the czar was on the road a lot and distances in the Russian empire where are
enormous.
And when he is gone from a Moscow and Saint Petersburg,
there was always this tendency to have these sort of cabal.
I mean,
they kind of get together and sort of plot and his son has the bad idea of
getting involved in this later as we shall see.
Yet there were incidents that his merciful side,
uh,
came through as well.
But when it came to treason,
he was less likely to be a merciful as the case of Alexi,
his ill fated son would,
would demonstrate.
Now,
Peter,
the great one thing is clear his head,
an enormous ambivalence about his role and his image as a czar.
His second wife was a Latvian peasant made and this horrified the boy are the
Boyers who,
who thought that this was just,
it was unbecoming.
How can you marry a,
a Latvian to begin with if you were Russian and Mary,
uh,
somebody,
who was a commoner,
um,
he was capable and they're a lot of paintings of him dressing up and playing
the,
the role of a,
of a czar,
uh,
you know,
dressing in fancy clothes,
but there's,
but they're more images of him identified with horribly worn boots with his toe
sometimes sneaking through at the end that seem to reflect his great personal
thrift,
uh,
wearing stockings.
It was said that he darned himself,
uh,
and a battered hat that he kept on wearing that he had worn at the battle of
Poltava in 1709 complete with a bullet hole that's supposedly tore through it.
I'm missing,
uh,
his,
head.
Um,
he liked the company of ordinary people.
Uh,
and this was a constant trait.
he identified himself with the Russian people and more about this in a while.
He avoided carriages.
He liked to walk.
He would leave the carers behind dismissing carriage drivers who are more well
dressed than he was.
And his guards,
he had ignored carefully,
uh,
crafted seating plans at dinner.
He jumped from table to table eating,
standing up.
He didn't like to sit down very much.
His back hurt or walking around,
he didn't like,
he couldn't stay still a very long,
um,
when he was lodged,
he liked living in your basic,
a Russian wouldn't peasant house,
uh,
such as you could find on the outskirts of Moscow.
One of the things that's very true about Moscow right into the 20th century is
that you'd all sorts of peasants living in the edge of Moscow living in these,
these,
uh,
these wooden houses.
And he liked that.
He said he slept well in the,
in these wooden houses.
Um,
and that probably is because of a very unhappy childhood,
listening to relative shouting each other and plotting to kill each other,
uh,
in the big house.
Um,
so,
um,
and,
and he never liked Moscow.
And we'll see more about that in a minute,
in part because of its overwhelming religious influence.
And that's one reason why he builds besides the quest for report,
uh,
on the,
the sea,
why he builds a Saint Petersburg.
Um,
he,
when travelling abroad,
he refused the fancy lodgings that were left for a reserve for such a
distinguished,
uh,
visitors in 17,
17,
uh,
in Paris,
Lindsay who's reports he went to a private house instead of the Louvre,
the Louvre,
the museum had a big,
uh,
palace,
which as I said before is,
where were the small boy,
Louis the 14th,
lived.
Uh,
and then,
um,
then it was burned in,
in 1871.
Uh,
and so he,
instead,
he just went to and rented a private house and fell asleep almost immediately.
Um,
he loves sleeping on ships.
He said he thought that the,
that the,
that the rocking of the waves rocked him to sleep.
And so he liked doing that.
Legend has him eating peasant food,
cabbage soup,
porridge,
uh,
meet,
with,
uh,
pickled cucumbers,
ham and cheese and crevasse,
which is a drink which have actually tasted from a fermented black bread.
Uh,
but he was not indifferent to a foreign food.
There was somebody found a,
an order,
he ordered 200 bottles of Irmi Taj wine.
Irmi Taj has a really wonderful now just horribly overpriced wine from the home
on the Left Bank of the,
of the home,
not very far away from where we live,
but it's totally out of price.
But Army Taj was a wine that was,
was known by Connoisseur in the 17th and 18th century.
And,
and ever since then,
and so,
you know,
for all the talk about eating,
eating cabbage and,
and,
and he didn't,
we were in a hurry.
People,
uh,
even then,
earned Ritaj costs a lot of money and,
and he,
uh,
you know,
he ordered 200 good bottles of army Taj wine.
So,
uh,
what else?
I wish I had been invited to these things.
Um,
he was very informal.
I mean,
he said that his legend that he just sort of grabbed these huge chunks of meat
and start gnawing on them like you would on a,
on a,
on a hot dog or something like that at a Yankee game.
Uh,
except that these other people were already dressed up and then the,
in the,
in the meat and the gravy was flying over them as he just sort of walked around
knowing on this stuff.
Um,
Sophia,
a Charlotte of Grunenberg.
I don't know the hell that is,
but,
but it's got to be some,
some,
uh,
royal hanger on row that is evident that he has not been taught how to eat
properly,
but she liked his natural manner and informality.
Uh,
the king,
King Frederick of Denmark found him ill mannered and inappropriate.
Um,
he liked to masquerade,
and again,
this is his personal ambivalence about his own role hanging around with were
ordinary people sleeping in,
in,
in peasant logics and that sort of thing.
He,
um,
he liked to dress up as a sailor and one thing that he always did when he went
on his grand tour is he always took fake names as if he was,
you know,
signing in into a hotel.
As,
you know,
Mr and Mrs. Jones Smith,
he would take the name of a commoner and we just assign him to a hotel.
You know,
Peter the great or whatever,
but he would,
he would,
he would go in with a name that wasn't his,
and again,
this is just his personal ambivalence about who he was and his uncertainty about
the role,
uh,
you know,
of that he had in his own,
in his own family yet.
And so this was a play acting that was part of his,
his life.
These ornate masquerades and charades that,
that,
that are part of his,
his complexity,
uh,
reveal something about his identity.
Then when you see these,
these portraits of him,
he looks for a czar like he looks like when these royal,
you know,
per people that,
that,
that were painted all the time in 60,
97,
he goes west with the name of Peter Mci loss.
Um,
and even in his own account books,
which he kept very carefully about how much money he had spent because he
wasn't,
he wasn't,
it wasn't a cheapskate,
but he,
but he really,
you know,
he paid attention to,
to,
to expenses,
to royal expenses,
personal expenses.
He refers to himself with a variety of names and titles as captain this kernel,
that general that,
uh,
and he's not,
he's not trying to hide his identity.
The future.
It was very obvious to see who he was is hey hand rising,
handwriting recognized by experts,
but roleplaying takes on dimensions of the state.
I mentioned,
I don't remember what context the other day that the most famous example is the
drunk in assembly.
It's sort of a mock parallel government with his buddies.
It has,
uh,
you know,
personnel who are his buddies,
those in favor,
lots of eating,
drinking,
et cetera.
Uh,
it has its statutes,
does this sort of mock constitution and its rituals that involve basically
getting,
you know,
getting wasted.
Um,
again,
this is part of a split personality about who he,
who he was and if he was correct.
I mean,
this is part of him saying that being a czar is more than just dressing up and
playing the role and going to fancy dances and hanging around with fancy people
who don't do a damn thing,
uh,
that you have to do the work,
you have to walk the walk.
Uh,
and that he did and that you had to manifest strength and firmness and brave
bravery and worthy deeds that would be recognized as being real deeds by
contemporaries.
And he constantly wants his son who was kind of a narrative.
Well that,
you know,
you better work harder,
you better,
you know,
working a little harder to pay more attention to what you're doing.
You've been or care about military things more than you do.
This is what I'm telling you.
You better do.
You better listen to what I'm doing.
Um,
but sometimes he just,
you know,
he needed,
he would drink a lot in Eli cause he just needed to relax.
I mean,
being a czar was a busy job.
He got up at four in the morning.
He was at his office for anybody else was.
And people began,
like in any business to be a 10th tended to,
you know,
am I there early enough?
You know,
did he see me that I am still here when it's getting dark,
of course it gets dark in the winter,
you know,
in,
in Saint Petersburg about,
uh,
you about,
about noon,
about noon.
Uh,
but anyway,
but he loved practical things.
He loved firefighting.
For example,
uh,
he had a passion for fireworks,
explosives,
cannon fire drums.
He played the drums.
He loved dancing and he loved religious thinking.
He lived this sort of choir music of Russian Orthodox,
uh,
services.
He loved to play chess and he loved to play billiards.
Uh,
and as I already said,
he loved mathematical instruments and telescopes.
He carried a telescope with him wherever he went,
and he knew how to use it and he knew what he was looking for.
Uh,
and he loved Globes.
He loved to see where things were he liked.
He liked to see that we,
that they map parts of Siberia that people didn't know what was there.
It was rather like parts of Africa before the 1880s,
just these big sort of blanks because nobody had ever been there.
Um,
and he was interested in that.
he was self taught.
Uh,
he didn't,
you didn't have to go to some fancy school if you were a czar,
you know,
uh,
to be a czar in training.
You had tutors.
There's all these folks did.
Um,
but,
uh,
but any made spelling mistakes,
which you can see.
I don't read Russian,
but he made spelling mistakes when he wrote his handwriting was awful and bad
handwriting as is the nemesis of,
of,
of historians,
uh,
to be sure.
But he built a private library and it wasn't just full of religious books.
It was a practical books about fortifications,
hydraulics,
artillery navigation and ship building.
But he also said he sang religious music.
He had many religious books to kind of standard liturgical texts that were the
stuff of,
of,
uh,
of a,
of religious enthusiasm and more modern theological theological works,
uh,
in the Russian Orthodox,
a tradition.
Another point about this sort of ambivalence about being czar is that he often
made a point of choosing his most trusted advisors from the ranks of commoners,
uh,
and gave them the right to become titled,
after a certain amount of time in the royal bureaucracy.
But sometimes he had a tendency to pick people whom you liked a lot,
but we're totally unqualified.
Miller military commanders who weren't,
who weren't,
um,
you weren't very good,
but you know what,
what he,
what he does is he cuts off Russian absolutism from this,
this totally religious,
uh,
culture.
Uh,
that was,
that represented 100% of,
of the official culture.
Uh,
uh,
in a real sense,
the culture of,
of,
uh,
pre Petrin that is pre Peter,
Russia,
uh,
because Russian culture was entirely religious.
If you went to Poland where I go off on,
as I've said before,
uh,
if you went to Krakow,
he Krokoff,
uh,
were called porn.
Lucas worked and I've been in Copernicus,
uh,
his work room.
It's just absolutely fantastic.
And,
and Cracow v you had a major university.
It was an important center of learning,
a diffusion of scientific ideas and the scientific revolution,
and later of enlightenment ideals in,
in Ville News,
which is the capital of,
of Lithuania.
Uh,
you had a university as well,
but there wasn't a university in Russia.
Uh,
there was no equivalent of the,
of the Royal Society that you're reading about in,
in London.
Uh,
that was very important in,
in the diffusion of the scientific revolution.
Or there's nothing like the Cat d media.
They see loss.
The Academy of Sciences,
uh,
in,
um,
uh,
in Paris,
which was,
was founded in 1666.
There's no legal tradition.
And so there's no law school.
There is no medical school.
Uh,
there is no secular culture.
90% of all the books that were published before Peter,
we're a devotional text in the church.
There was no word literally in Russian for the state or for the monarchy or for
the government.
They did not exist.
The,
the state was an abstraction,
but in the person of the czar,
it was,
was a reality.
Now,
the boy,
ours in the 16,
16th and 1670,
some of them began to learn Latin and Polish.
Uh,
and diplomacy is still in Latin until the end of the 17th century.
And then as you know,
it becomes French.
Um,
but so what,
what about now?
What about his accomplishments besides the ones I've already mentioned,
to which I'll return a little bit?
Uh,
Moscow via had already conquered the vulgar basin in the 16th century where
they're nomadic tattooers were a ta.
Te Ars.
This was important because it's the black earth region of rich agricultural
there.
And at what happens there is what happens in what happens in Russia is what
happens in impression as well.
And in other parts of eastern Europe,
particularly in the half for domains,
is you have to make it very bad pun,
a resurfacing of,
uh,
of the region by people forced into surf contracts.
They become not contracts to become legally,
uh,
um,
legally part of the land,
literally.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
this follows the,
the,
the ad to the arrival of,
of,
uh,
the expansion of a serfdom expands along with,
the Russian Russian empire.
Um,
they already held Siberia and they reached the Pacific Ocean in the 1640s.
Uh,
so this,
I already said what the percent of what the number of miles square miles that
were increased,
but an increases from six to 16 million of the population.
They expand north to Archangel.
So this gives them a port,
but a frozen one.
And as I already said,
south and southeast to the expense of the Turks.
But Peter wanted a navy and you know,
if you're going to have a sort of circular reasoning,
if you want to have a navy,
you have to have a port.
And if you're going to have a port,
then you have to have a navy.
Why not?
Uh,
and so he,
he first built a navy on rivers using Dutch ship masters from,
he once said that if he wasn't the tsar of all the Russians what he would want
to be,
it would be a rush of being an English admiral.
He learned Dutch and Dutch is a very difficult language.
Uh,
in 1696,
while the Turkish war went on,
or one of them,
he went off to western Europe incognito as an embassy soldier.
Again,
it was part of his,
his gamesmanship is pretend games.
And there he learned carpentry in a very serious way.
He went to the light and men medical school because he wanted to see how you
did.
They dissected bodies.
And so we went in there to,
uh,
and then he went to London.
Uh,
and he,
uh,
along the Thames,
the major port,
uh,
obviously if the world event along with Amsterdam,
and he learned shipbuilding there as well.
Uh,
and,
uh,
because the building of ships was to him,
the application of rationality,
of reason thinking and experimentation.
This got him interested in the scientific revolution.
Uh,
there's nothing to a surprising about that is the essence of the scientific
revolution.
He may have even attended a Quaker meeting,
but we're not sure about that.
But the problem was if you have a basically landlocked power and want to get to
the sea,
then you better have a navy.
He'd learned to sail when he was young,
but on,
uh,
on the river,
and this also by the way,
gets him interested in baroque and these kinds of broke masquerades that he had
back in,
in Moscow and then in St Petersburg,
uh,
as well.
So,
um,
in,
in all of this,
what he does is he makes to use an expression that I've already used before in
the context of absolutism.
He makes the boy out while he's building his navy and expanding Russia.
He makes the boy,
our junior partners in absolutism.
That phrase again.
Now they're only about 200 to 300.
Boy,
our families,
they owned,
by the way,
40,000 serfs,
own 40,000 serves just these 200 to 300 families.
And they build huge houses in the 17th century in Moscow with very old fashion.
Traditional Russian,
uh,
architecture.
Um,
the,
the empire,
the Russian empire was rather like Charlemagne's empire in 800 and the
coronation at ochin or x,
La Chapelle and all of that.
And that you have this,
it,
this Brock cracy that's a very,
very,
uh,
you know,
it's not really a bureaucracy,
but you've got these royal officials representing the royal will,
but,
but the actual impact in this vast expanse of the Russian empire isn't that
great.
There's nobody telling people what to do on a day to day or even a month to
month basis.
But yet there's an enhanced sense of,
of,
of obligation to the czar of all,
uh,
of the Russian people.
There was an,
there's an advanced sense of state and of organization,
and that also is one of the things to put in,
in neons.
He creates committees of advisers that in ways are not that different than the
kinds of ministries that would evolve in Western absolute rulers,
uh,
absolute state and states and in non absolute states,
as well.
And so by 1708 and 1709,
he has created a more European style administration for this fast empire.
Now the,
he wants to build a capital city and that's where St Petersburg comes from.
Um,
uh,
he,
it had been Swedish territory and his victories gives him a of this land.
I,
once I went to,
uh,
visit his,
you know,
the Summer Palace that he,
that he created and that Nicholas the second I love so much there.
Um,
and so he constructs this new capital.
Now what's important about the construction of St Petersburg?
I don't know how few people have ever been there.
I haven't been there for a very,
very long time,
but that this city is not like Moscow at all.
When you look at Moscow,
you see these old traditional,
the skyline is dominated by churches.
The influence of the Russian Orthodox Church,
Saint Peters,
who was completely different.
It is a classical example.
Classic.
It's an example of classic great power,
absolute urban planning.
It has a long boulevard.
The Nevsky prospect,
very important.
In 1917,
uh,
the most dominant buildings are not churches.
They are state buildings,
they are state structures.
So it's a different place.
It reminds you of Madrid,
it reminds you of Berlin,
it reminds you of Versailles and it reminds you of the Post [inaudible] Paris
that has post 1850s in 1860 Paris.
It is,
it is the example of the street and imperialism,
what I call the imperialism of the straight line where you have large boulevards
and you can march armies down to reviewing stands and all of that totally
different than Moscow.
And the religious leaders did not like Peter because Peter is bringing in to a
Russian culture foreign elements.
Uh,
they're already suspicious of,
of the implementation or the,
the,
the annexation of broke religious forms,
architectural forms,
uh,
and liturgical influences from Austria and from central Europe.
And now they got a guy who's telling the czar,
the boy,
ours women to dress like Western European women.
And he's telling the at at a time when beards meant a great deal religiously,
he's telling the men to shave off their beards.
He's telling them the men to a two wheeled forks and knives as well as weapons.
And to adopt Russian non Russian customs to bring them into Russia.
And so there's tremendous tension with,
with the church,
but he remains,
you know,
he is a true believer,
but he is,
he is bringing into Russian religious culture changes that were a deeply,
uh,
deeply resented.
Uh,
some aristocrats began to put on Western style wigs,
uh,
such as you could find at the court of Versailles.
Women had to wear high heels and sort of their sort of tottering long and
falling,
you know,
on the cobblestones wearing high heels I and European style,
uh,
addresses.
And he promulgated degrees as czar about daily life.
And this is a big a transformation as to his son.
His son was more under the influence of these traditional religious influences
and he,
uh,
is plotting against his own father when Peter on one of his trips has to return
back to,
to Russia.
Uh,
and in 17,
16,
17,
a 17,
16,
17,
18,
Alexi had taken his mother's side in the divorce and did not like the Latvian
peasant.
Uh,
a second wife.
He also didn't like military service.
He was lazy.
And his father said,
I see you're spending more of your time in item list and in taking care of
business at this crucial time,
but Alexei doesn't get the,
doesn't get the point.
And he begins to,
to plot in various ways with Desitin boy ours,
uh,
and he goes off and gets the support of the emperor of Austria to wage a war
against his own father.
Terrible idea.
And when he returns,
his father orders him,
he orders him tortured and under torture.
Alexi,
who probably dies of,
of,
of cold,
not of torture,
uh,
in a very,
frozen,
uh,
sell a name,
Boyer accomplices.
And these people are toast.
Uh,
obviously,
uh,
he probably the son died of probably TB,
but it related to all of this other business in is we can state,
um,
and so that was the end of the sun.
But,
uh,
what lasted a longer than Alexi was the European Association of Russian culture.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Peter the great has,
has books translated from the West,
including John Locke,
uh,
into,
into Russian.
And this itself was a remarkable accomplishment because after all,
the Russian Orthodox Church man had been not interested in the renaissance and
all not interested in the scientific revolution and all.
And by 17,
10,
Russian students are being sent abroad to foreign universities,
particularly in Italy,
but also in France and in England.
Uh,
and they're studying practical things like marble work and metalwork and copper
work,
and not just ship building,
but they're also studying the life of the mind,
uh,
and,
in,
in a way,
it's,
it's possible to argue,
which is what I'm arguing that,
and I'm not the first to do it,
but Peter the great was in many ways himself,
uh,
a child of European rationalism of scientific,
culture of rationality.
And,
uh,
have,
at least in the earlier stages of,
uh,
of the enlightenment.
He was not against the church,
but he thought that people were wasting time,
uh,
being monks and,
and,
and monks and other,
and other people were all over the place.
And they're Russian Orthodox equivalent.
Uh,
he wouldn't believe whatever wag once set of monks,
you know,
I,
uh,
I sleep,
I eat.
I did just,
uh,
and they prayed,
of course.
And to him this was not useless because it didn't serve the state.
It didn't serve the denied the nastic interests of,
of,
uh,
of the,
the dynasty which he identified with the Russian people.
He did say ty,
he did not ever imagine,
uh,
the abandonment of the table of ranks,
which is set everybody in a hierarchy,
uh,
that not for a minute and we're talking about the end of the 17th and 18th
century.
But he believed that it was important to turn,
take the tools of science to take the tools of rational thought and apply them
to the good of the state.
Even if he saw that good of the state as an in,
you know,
ships that could lob canon of balls even further against hostile ships and that
kind of thing.
Uh,
but he founds the first Russian museum,
the first school of navigation.
Uh,
the first school of this and that,
uh,
there,
there are a hundred times more books,
pamphlets,
Prince and maps,
uh,
produced in Russia,
under the time of Peter the great than there had been in the whole previous,
uh,
a century.
Um,
Peter as Lindsey Hughes has argued,
was highly suspicious of any alternative to state service,
uh,
especially the mastic,
a way of life,
which I've already said.
Uh,
but he thought that it should be,
it should be channeled through state obligations,
be their taxes or labor duties.
Uh,
at the same time,
he's equally suspicious of the godless.
So he was remain very Russian,
but it was importation of,
of,
of a more western ways of looking things,
uh,
that made,
that were very,
uh,
important.
He said he wrote once at the chief thing is to know your duties and our Edx by
heart and not put off things until tomorrow,
like his son did a four.
How can a state government,
uh,
exist if edicts or not put into use,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
their lives,
uh,
should be,
be better.
Uh,
that the concept of the state,
uh,
was fundamentally new to Russia,
but gradually came into existence and his accomplishments had,
uh,
a lot,
to do,
uh,
with that he wrote his son and 17 and forests that I may die tomorrow.
But be sure that you have little pleasure if you fail to follow my example,
you must love everything that contributes to the glory and honor of the
Fatherland.
You must love loyal advisors and servants,
whether they'd be foreigners or our own people,
and spare no effort to serve the common good,
the common good.
It comes right out of enlightened thought.
That right comes out of lock and the,
and,
and those folks.
If my advice is,
is lost in the wind and you do not do as I wish,
I do not recognize you as my son.
And that in the end,
what,
uh,
what came in the long run,
he remained a fanatically Russian patriot.
The father of his people.
Uh,
his admiration for foreign things and approaches was tempered.
Its use,
argues his devotion to Russia,
which he oversaw the common good.
I became a real concept,
uh,
and one that unfortunately,
some of his successors,
uh,
didn't,
take a terribly seriously.
But you know,
in conclusion,
he di he defiantly deliberately in effectively broke with tradition.
And in doing so,
he made himself sort of an outsider to traditional Russian ways of looking at
this thing.
And so this ambivalence that was part of his personal life,
the way he lived would be con constant theme in subsequent Russian history.
And still in many ways is today between Slava fields in western islanders.
Those are the people that look inside the Russia,
uh,
to,
finding,
uh,
what they think to be eternal truth.
And those people that want to Trump 10% look looks with a look to the west.
And that,
uh,
in Neon is what Peter the Great I did above all.
And for which he shall boast most be remembered next time to the enlightenment.
And some people whom you might not think of at first glance,
who teamed terribly enlightened.
See on Wednesday.